after everything was said and done the
wolf of Wall Street had scammed
investors out of 200 million dollars if
you want to know how exactly he got this
money or how he spent it so far without
being caught then make sure to check out
my last two videos in this video we'll
be looking at how Jordan Belfort was
finally exposed
starting off Stratton Oakmont first
encounter with law enforcement would be
with the SEC in 1992 the SEC would
accuse a brokerage firm of both stock
manipulation and defrauding investors
their evidence for stock manipulation
was a company called Nova Capital Inc
between December 1989 and August 1990
the stock price would over double from
$4 to $9.25 a gain that didn't correlate
with any corporate news or market forces
the SEC estimated that Stratton Oakmont
Crawford at about eleven million dollars
from the manipulation now again though
the numbers make obvious that there was
some sort of stock manipulation it's
basically impossible to prove securities
fraud with down insider cracking ask for
the defrauding investors accusation the
SEC accused three executives for
misrepresenting and omitting facts about
companies they pitched investors this
was much easier to prove simply by
tapping phone lines or posing as phony
investors Stratton Oakmont knew that the
SEC really wouldn't be able to prove the
securities fraud but they wanted the SEC
off her back so they agreed to a
settlement where the company would pay
2.5 million dollars in fines and that
three executives would have to pay
$100,000 each personally in fines on top
of this Jordan Belfort would have to
step down from running the company
Jordan wouldn't actually do this but he
would sell his share of Stratton Oakmont
he felt confident that the SEC couldn't
build up enough evidence against him to
charge him for securities fraud and this
would actually hold true to the very end
Jordan's downfall would actually be the
FBI agent Kohan and Coleman would begin
investing in the firm and Jordan Belfort
in 1992 they spent a considerable amount
of time trying to buster in Belfort from
money laundering cases relate to
Stratton Oakmont but his well-paid staff
simply wouldn't crack furthermore Swiss
banks were also not very willing to
share banking information with the FBI
on the basis of a money-laundering case
so the FBI switched to a different
approach tax evasion tax evasion and
money laundering are often used
interchangeably but there is a subtle
difference one can evade taxes without
laundering money by simply not paying
the taxes but one cannot launder money
without also committing tax evasion so
when Jordan was shipping over millions
of dollars to Switzerland he was not
only laundering money but also
committing tax evasion
I guess Jordan wasn't paying his money
launderers as well as he was paying his
chat nights because FBI was able to find
witnesses testify that they helped
Jordan smuggle money in Switzerland
these witnesses were also able to
provide information about the bankers
Jordan was using in Geneva it still took
a lot of time but this evidence would
eventually prove sufficient enough for
the Swiss authorities to mandate the
bankers to cooperate with the
investigation once they got to Jordans
was a banker it didn't take long to
gather evidence for John and Danny or in
the movie Donnie's money laundering in
the movie we only see Jordan being
arrested but in reality both Jordan and
Danny would be arrested on the basis of
money laundering the maximum fine from
my laundering is actually only five
hundred thousand dollars and the
reduction of this fine wouldn't be
nearly enough to convince Jordan and
Gainey to cooperate what would really
scare them though was a prison sentence
of up to 20 years a chance a
significantly reduced his term would
finally get that lead Stratton ice to
crack and this is how the securities
fraud occurring with dinner at Oakmont
would finally surface in the movie we
see Jordan agreeing to be wired but he
ends up passing a note to Donny worrying
that he is wired in reality this would
not happen Jordan and Danny would
actually both be wired and be forced to
cooperate for several years of evidence
collecting agent Cohen says that there
was no resistance from either individual
and that they both quickly caved to turn
on strat Oakland when presented with up
to 25 years in jail Jordan and Danny
would also both pleaded guilty but the
final verdict for the case took years
and they would have been convicted to a
2004 eventually the
sentence for Jordan came out to be four
years in prison along with 110 million
dollars in fines asked for Danny he was
also sentenced to four years in prison
but he actually had to pay more fines at
two hundred million dollars as Jordan
had stepped out of trot Oakmont much
earlier than Denny
both men were also mandated to pay 50
percent of the future incomes to pay
back investors until the fines are paid
off Jordan would be released in 22
months and Danny would be released in 39
months and so far
Jordan has actually paid back thirteen
million dollars which sounds like a
sizable chunk but in reality 11 million
of these dollars was seized during his
arrest so he has actually only paid back
2 million meanwhile he's working as a
motivational speaker running up to 100
thousand dollars per speech so he still
making a very good living earning well
over seven figures a year Jordan claims
that he has been paying back as much as
they can but FBI agent disagree claim
that Jordan hasn't been making payments
in years whether or not Jordan will
actually pay this amount back is unclear
but at least he isn't partaking anymore
securities frauds anyways that's all
Jordan made a fortune spent a fortune
how he was finally caught in his
situation today if you guys thought this
video series explained Jordan's real
life well then make sure drop a like and
make her subscribe to see more questions
just like these logically answered but
until then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on
the next one